reaction the host of candace on the
daily wire candace owens
along with fox news contributor leo 2.0
tarot
welcome back both of you candace this
was something i pointed out for years on
this program
every two years every four years any
conservative any republican
you're racist sexist misogynist
homophobic xenophobic islamophobic now
you can add transphobic
uh you want dirty air and water and some
republican is going to take your grandma
and grandpa in a wheelchair and throw
them over a cliff in an advertisement
it's predictable but now it's every
issue your reaction
it is every issue and it's obviously
just name-calling and it seems to me
good to be completely foolish that
people are not awake to what the
democrat strategy is here
you know they use people that are false
prophets like lebron james to
propagate a lot of these lies
particularly the black lives matter lie
that seems to be almost the biggest one
the race lie um has been permeating
throughout every element of culture
you have lebron james who lives amongst
white people in a 100 million dollar
100 million dollar bel air mansion who
is protected by white people protected
by
presumably undercover officers and
things of that nature everywhere he goes
and
you know to his games back and forth
there are police officers that are
constantly surrounding him
and yet he puts out this lie and the
president is correct to call him
president trump is correct to say
that lebron james himself is racist not
only that he doesn't care about black
people
if lebron james cared about black people
he'd point to the truth the truth is
that
if you care about black people you have
to talk about black on black crime
upwards the 95 of black homicide victims
are killed by other black people
what he actually cares about is just
making sure that he himself is situated
as a king
while the peasants beneath him he calls
himself the king the peasants beneath
him and that
follow him all invest in this lie
destroy their own communities and yes
kill each other as would have been the
circumstance if that police officer had
not
intervened every single weekend
and i this goes back to the biden obama
years leo
i can come on this program every monday
and tell you how many people were shot
in the city of chicago
i could tell you many how many people
were shot and killed in the city of
chicago and a lot of other big cities
every single weekend murder rates are
skyrocketing
all over the country there is no there
this defund the police
dismantle police it's not working why
don't we ever hear the names of all the
people shot
every weekend why is it only
a case that can be used politically why
isn't we only hear about those lives
it's very simple it's all about power
and what you're describing is
what has been going on in democratic
cities
for years listen they talk about racism
i'm a civil rights attorney i know what
systemic racism
is it does not exist in chicago in la
in baltimore when the people running the
show
are black people brown people chief of
police they
only play the white officer card
against a black victim candidates point
out all the numbers but
they play the race game and guess what
the democrats drink that kool-aid
there is a disconnection between the
democratic hierarchy
that live like kings and may brainwash
the democratic voters who live like
peasants i want to make one other point
that white sign that you made reference
to that sign is
very very insulting and basically the
extreme
left has declared war on white americans
and white police officers
and the democratic leadership will not
say a word because they are in bed with
the extreme left
that's what's going on in america it
happens not every two years or four
years
is going on 24 7 sean hannity
all right leo 2.0 terrell candace holmes
by the way
again congrats on the baby um we're very
happy for you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else